Oh No hello mr. Satyarthi oh hello my
name is Adam Smith calling from the
Nobel Prize website in Stockholm
congratulations on the award of the
Nobel Prize thank you so much thank you
very very much
the great honour and hundreds of
millions of children deprived of your
childhood in health and education and
fundamental right to freedom the great
moment for all those children and thank
you very much for that all of you that's
very kind of you thank you what message
do you hope that the prize award will
deliver to the world that this will help
visibility and attention to the cause of
children who are elected and not divided
between also inspire the individuals
activists governments business houses
corporate to work hand in hand to fight
it out I'm quite hopeful about it that
the determination of the people will
help in mobilizing
with our support for the call marvelous
this will focus a lot of attention on
your work how can people around the
world help you with your mission
everyone must acknowledge and feel that
child slavery still exists in the world
in its ugliest face and form and this
isn't evil this is crime against
humanity which is intolerable which is
unacceptable and which not go that
strength of civilization that we
developed first of all and secondly
there is a need of higher amount of
political will there is a need of higher
amounts of corporate engagement and and
of the public to work
for everybody have a responsibility to
serve and protect the children on the
planet thank you and I suppose there is
end child slavery week coming up in
November so everybody a week from 19
November 25th of November and that would
be an annual event which we would be
organizing a year on different aspects
of China and this year we are demanding
to the initial community bank that the
addition of child must be incorporated
into the Millennium Development Goal or
Development Goal thank you very much
indeed for speaking to us and again
congratulations on the award of the
Nobel Prize thank you thank you all
right